[Musique]
le président du Département Cyril Melkor
a présenté ses vœux à la presse ce mardi
30 janvier au Palais de la source il est
extrêmement important pour nous de
discuter de dialoguer avec les
représentants de la presse parce que
c'est un moyen d'informer nos citoyens
de nos actions nous avons pour souci la
transparence de ce que nous faisons
faire en sorte que les gens qui payent
les impôts on le droit de savoir ben
comment le département dépense son
budget et bien en développant ces axes
en expliquant ben nous apportons des
informations qui qui va vers qui vont
vers les les citoyens et ça pour ça la
presse ben c'est c'est la presse qui
occupe le rôle essentiel c'est pour cela
que je rends hommage à la presse
réionnaise et je formule le vœux que les
deux organes de presse écrites puissent
surmonter leur problème actuel
l'occasion pour le président de
présenter les grands axes sur lesquels
la collectivité va œuvré cette année
nous voulons faire en sorte que cette
réunion qui se caractérise par son bien
vivre ensemble puisse continuer à
développer son modèle puisse continuer à
cheminer sur le chemin de la prospérité
de la promotion pour les jeunes pour les
familles lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales faire en sorte que le
jeune qui veut s'insérer durablement de
dans la vie puisse trouver à le faire en
renforçant sa sa ses formations sa
mobilité professionnelle et que les
chefs d'entreprise jouent le jeu de
l'embauche locale et ça aussi c'est
important en clair que nous soyons tous
citoyens au service des réunionnés
entreprises organismes de formation
département dans un élan de solidarité
pour lutter contre le chômage qui est un
véritable fléo et un autre sujet qui à
mes yeux est extrêmement important c'est
de R de faire en sorte que la Réunion et
bien soit dans sa diversité
puisse offrir la meilleure qualité de
vie environnementale nous avons en
gestion la forêt rignonnaise les espace
naturel sensible donc le verdissement de
l'île la qualité de vie environnementale
la protection de la biodiversité ce sont
des sujets sur lesquels nous travaillons
et à ce jour le plan 1 million d'arbres
et bien on avance bien puisqu'on en est
à 300000 arbres déjà plantés sur les
espaces du département le président a
également abordé différents thèmes dans
le domaine du soci des r de la culture
ou encore du
sport